[Musique]
attention regardez bien séquence muppet
show nous est acquis pour passe dans
l'autre camp cyril vous avez qui pour
clore un autre message appelait qui
passe mal autres qu'on ne sait rien vous
impliquez me charrière l'autre con
commissariat
vous appliquez pour passez moi l'autre
con mais ça rien
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais je sais mon deuil ouais vraiment
jean luc addor ya un autre explique on
en a pris c'est vrai que c'est le début
de votre duo infernal entre thierry
moreau et jean michel meyer et il y en a
eu tellement dont à moscou sous mille
l'histoire du téton bah oui je n'ai pas
en fait et l'autre qui ne comprend rien
jean michel mr regardé c'était donc les
premiers 4/3 c'est arrivé le 8 novembre
2012 et plus repris y en a eu plein
comme ça avec eux dont le téton c'est
parti le jean michel qui bloque sur une
vanne c'est rigolo mais au bout d'un
moment ça devient gênant ça coûtait pas
compris
il était tombé à celui des tons d'accord
mais les murs tombent d'accord de haut
bah oui c'est ça la femme mais comme tu
veux on s'en fout et les miens la
remarque vaut pour des tons et les
mirettes et on met les miens
je me tais tu es nouvelle tête est
tombée à chouette
bonjour oui oui si l'asie à jour là
c'était un mail de maïtena biraben qui
nous avait envoyé si elle avait signé
téton ou moi on dire fierté on soyons
les femmes sont au soyons fiers voilà
c'est exactement et donc du coup il
avait répondu tu es ton eau et les miens
toujours selon ses moyens
oui et on est et on s'est écrit comment
ton mais vraiment oui à rennes ça
contient compris alors les deux il ya eu
un autre extrait je voulais vous montrer
regardez c'est du jean michel maire
comme on les aime dialogue surréaliste
entre jean michel et françois whisky
faisait à l'époque sa première émission
moi je fume plus mais voilà